bonjour morad el hattab merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france
on l'a vu à beaucoup de réactions de la
communauté internationale
un conflit de plus plus de 30 ans
maintenant qui s'est interrompue mais
qui sait jamais vraiment arrêté dans les
années 90 la guerre entre les deux
régions avaient provoqué 30000 morts
doit-on s'attendre à une guerre aussi
meurtrière cette fois j'ai envie de dire
eh bien c'est de lui rappeler que ces
deux états ont toujours été en guerre
larvée depuis lors cessé de fumer depuis
le 16 mai 1994 soit trois ans après leur
indépendance respective
ces deux états qui ont chahuté jamais eu
de relations diplomatiques
même vous en tant que journaliste si
vous rendez avec un visa arménie en
azerbaïdjan vous êtes refoulés donc
effectivement il y aura éventuellement
une guerre tant que les grandes
puissances est à dire les états unis la
russie
interviendront par ci intervienne et qui
arrive à aller mettre tous les deux ou
table de négociations ça s'arrêtera
assez rapidement
comment on peut expliquer ce regain de
violence durant ces derniers mois dans
cette région
alors je vais vous surprendre mais là je
suis une analyse purement géopolitique
ça rappelle beaucoup le conflit du haut
karabagh le contexte géorgien en vrai
vous avez une guerre du pétrole qui ne
dit pas son nom pour maintenir les
points de tension stratégiques
c'est-à-dire que vous avez une pince
géostratégique pour diminuer l'influencé
de la russie dans le caucase et
l'asphyxié en ruinant ses coopérations
type rapallo de 1922 où il y avait un
échange de matières stratégiques russes
contre des technologies allemand soit
les coopérations russe avec l'europe de
l'est de l'ouest et je vous renvoie au
projet nord stream
vous avez une sorte de projet bilatéral
qu en train de se faire entre l'europe
et la russie sans les américains
et les américaines ou le tonnerre
absolument pas et donc pour permettre de
rééquilibrer les balances des paiements
américain vous avez par extension
l'instrumentalisation de l'europe de
l'est
poussé au belliciste et la turquie et
c'est très important de le comprendre
parce que c'est
je vous donne un point de vue vraiment
purement géostratégique d'initié ça
ressemble c'est la guerre de yougoslavie
d une guerre qui était dirigée contre
l'indépendance énergétique de l'union
européenne
le fameux projet lean âge as tu du
fameux projet d'oléoduc contre le projet
américain en baux et à chaque fois que
c'est le cas on en flammes la zone
tampon mais c'est exactement ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est de faire aussi
passer les russes pour des méchants et
en europe impuissante de s'organiser
sans les états unis
il faut vraiment voir l'arrière fond du
conflit tous les petits commentaires du
moment christ la turquie intervient
ceci ça tout ça c'est tout ce qui m'a
conté ce seront les grandes manoeuvres
des grandes puissances et soual assure
guy justement va essayer de tirer profit
de cette situation et d'un autre côté la
russie va-t-elle jouer son rôle de
médiateur comment elle va arbitrer ce
conflit bah de toute façon ça va se
régler entre les états unis et la russie
le reste c'est même pas la peine d'en
parler c'est des gens qui souffle sur
les braises
donc moi je pense que ce genre des coups
de fil entre donald trump et vladimir
poutine ces prochains jours
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez étrange
à chaque fois qu'un projet prend corps
pour l'europe en termes de manière
internet d'indépendance énergétique avec
une coopération russe à chaque fois vous
voyez s'enflammer des zones comme qui
sont des non sens géostratégique
vous aviez un problème est que la grèce
et la turquie ya pas très longtemps elle
a maintenant bizarrement d'un seul coup
une guerre qui renaît on ne sait pas
pourquoi des gens qui se tirent dessus
des civils marc si vous prenez un peu de
recul vous comprenez très bien c'est une
guerre de pétrole qui ne dit pas son nom
le premier en france c'est que je suis
un des rares à donner cette analyse
c'est qu'en france on a délaissé
l'analyse you stratégique du pétrole
mais si vous analysez sous ce prisme là
vous comprendrez à court terme très
prochainement que ma vision est celle
que partagée par le plus grand nombre
d'initiés on connaît l'importance de la
stabilité de cette région et pourquoi
les pourparlers de paix sont dans
l'impasse depuis depuis des années
j'étais dans l'impasse on a eu un de
manière sporadique une classe 9 triaire
en 2016 en 2020 et vous constaterez
comme moi que depuis 1994 il y en a pas
eu tant que ça à lui deux fois 2016 2020
et puis là aujourd'hui à 2020
aujourd'hui donc je pense que dd pour
parer ou se faire assez rapidement et
que très rapidement j'en suis intimement
convaincu vont se retrouver à la table
des négociations
le président arménien et le président
d'azerbaïdjan à moscou et à washington
deux dernières questions rapidement à ce
que les clients un rôle à jouer dans ce
conflit non non parce que l'iran ça
viendra après l'iran n'a pas de rôle
spécifique à jouer même si vous devez
bien comprendre que quand il est
question de pétrole
la question iranienne n'est pas loin
mais encore une fois je vous dis c'est
ce seront les grandes manoeuvres des
grandes puissances qui vont qui vont se
mettre en oeuvre qui vont régler cette
situation tendue cercle c'est pas la
première fois et nous aurons pas une
guerre mondiale comme j'entends certains
qu'il a commencé de par ce conflit
il en est hors de question et les russes
ou bien compris l'arrière-plan de la
situation ainsi que l'allemagne
d'ailleurs qui ne dit pas un grand mot
je vous assure et pour être en contact
avec des spécialistes allemands ils ont
compris que c'était une guerre de
pétrole qui ne disait pas son nom
merci beaucoup morad el hattab d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes géopolitologue